last week veterans United asked for your
Mother's Day messages to some of the
moms on the front lines of the corona
virus pandemic and now we want to share
some of those letters with you for that
we bring in Chief Master Sergeant
anaconda Hinton from the DC Air National
Guard nice to see you ma'am you think
about moms who are celebrating today as
well they should be and then we think
about all the moms who are on the
frontlines whether it's deployed with
the military or on the front lines of
the corona virus pandemic who can't be
celebrated really in the way that we'd
like to with flowers and breakfast etc
what options are there for them so at
this time we have several members and
just like you say they are actually
today serving in different various
locations in DC helping out with da op
support with important citizens of the
District of Columbia and unfortunately
they can't be home with their children
today
so I sent several text messages and I'm
sure several other members of the
District of Columbia national bar have
sent them messages just to say thank you
for your service and just being out
there in the front lines and what are
they doing specifically we have Airmen
and soldiers out there at certain
supermarkets in Southeast DC we also
have members who are doing screening at
various hospitals for testing Kovach 19
testing we also have members who are
preparing alternate care facility that
will be opening up soon so they're out
there working about the clock so yes
last week we asked for some messages and
I think there there have been a lot that
have come in correct yes Oh awesome can
you share some of them for us sure I
have one that says dear hero I'm a
military spouse for 20 years as a mother
to proud military brats who went through
three deployments I'm very happy to
volunteer and create paid for it with
Operation Gratitude
by writing to you I know why you serve I
know my life is better for it
Thank You Laura happy Mother's Day dear
hero words cannot express my gratitude
for your service and sacrifice for this
country I can imagine how hard it is to
be
from loved ones during this time I hope
you know you appreciate it your courage
inspires me and so many others I'm
keeping you in my prayers and you're
sending love with this note of gratitude
thank you for all you do with love and
thanks in need Calvin with love and hugs
you're the best thank you for your
service you rock Sidney what love and
thinks the cowman family that's fabulous
absolutely fantastic I think we saw
there a couple of pictures with you with
your son correct correct Oh awesome what
are you what are you all doing for
Mother's Day right now we just relaxing
my husband went out and picked up some
dinner foot and actually my son is
asleep so which is great the best
Mother's Day present is a little bit of
peace and quiet well we appreciate you
joining us thank you happy happy
Mother's Day to you and obviously to
those moms who are out there on the
front lines we're glad we got a chance
to to share those messages thank you
thank you